können wir jetzt sprechen ich freue mich
dass Sie in Dresden verbunden bin mit
Professor Werner Patzelt
Politikwissenschaftler der uns bei
Phoenix durch viele Analysen begleitet
hat Herr Professor Patzelt das sind
durchaus noch einmal ganz besondere
Werte die hier vorgetragen wurden und
wenn wir jetzt einfach mal bei dieser
Sonntagsfrage beginnen
eine
Regierungspartei die gleich aufliegt mit
der AFD wie alarmiert sind sie darüber
man sollte sich nicht an der Oberfläche
mit seinen
alarmgefühlen aufhalten man sollte in
die Tiefe gehen die AFD gibt es ja schon
längst bevor sie derzeitige Regierung
gegeben hat und wurde essen sollte man
die Ursachen für den Aufstieg der AFD
nicht einfach in der Politik der andere
Regierung sehen sondern sie liegen
tiefer und am Ende des vorigen Beitrags
wurde ja schon die Migrationsthematik
angesprochen das treibt viele Deutsche
um das hat zum Aufstieg der AFD geführt
und es ist ja kein Ende der bisherigen
deutschen Migrationspolitik abzusehen
und das ist einer der Faktoren die das
Vertrauen der andere Regierung schenken
nicht der einzige dazu kommt die
Energiepolitik Klimapolitik
heizungsgesetz und die deutsche Haltung
im russischen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
hinzu also sie sagen ist eine Mischung
von Themen und von Unzufriedenheiten die
die Wähler zu AFD treibt sie haben die
Ampel angesprochen genug gesagt deren
schlechte Performance kann jetzt nicht
die alleinige Erklärung sein dennoch
kann man über diese Performance durchaus
sprechen ein beliebtheitswert der
sozusagen im unteren messbaren Bereich
liegt nach ungefähr anderthalb Jahren
Regierungszeit das ist schon erstaunlich
ja das hat ganz wesentlich damit zu tun
dass die Hoffnungen die man sich in den
Kreisen der ampelparteien machte und
jene Hoffnungen die die Bürger verbunden
haben
bei der Bundestagswahl bei SPD und
Grünen diese Hoffnungen im Puppen sich
in vielen Bereichen Illusionen schauen
Sie der Pazifismus der die grüne lange
Zeit so attraktiv gemacht hat er ist
voll und ganz zerplatzt eigentlich ist
derzeit keine Partei eine die stärker
die Krieg Führung unterstützt als die
Grüne Partei was die Klimapolitik
betrifft sehen alle Deutschen sind die
meisten Deutschen ein dass man etwas
gegen Klimawandel der von Menschen
gemacht wird Unternehmen soll und
theoretisch will man dann das Ende des
fossilen Zeitalters aber wenn es
praktisch wird und dann auch persönlich
teuer zu werden tot ja dann merkt man ja
das eine ist was ich bevorzuge wenn es
mir gut geht wenn ich keinerlei Probleme
habe etwas anderes ist meine Haltung
wenn ich dafür einstellt und gar noch
mit meinem eigenen Einkommen dafür
bezahlen muss es ist einfach so dass
viele Illusionen die dieses Land in den
fetten Jahren als die merkelregierung
Errungenschaften der Schröder-Regierung
verzehren konnte dass vieles
Selbstverständlichkeiten aus jedem
fetten Jahren jetzt an den harten rauen
Wänden der Wirklichkeit zerplatzen und
natürlich wird dann die Regierung die
all dem das Gesicht gibt und die dagegen
ansteuern muss wird alles das die
Regierung nicht unbeschuhen lassen
Herr Professor Patzelt wenn sie
sozusagen jetzt analysieren dass für
viele Wähler jetzt oder für die die
befragt wurden ein Grund des Missfallens
ist das Erwartungen in dieser
ampelregierung nicht eingelöst wurden
muss man quasi noch mal glaube ich in
einer zweiten Ebene auch noch Fragen
können wir wollen Sie auch ein bisschen
tiefer noch mal betreiben wie ist denn
sozusagen auch um das Zusammenspiel in
dieser Ampel bestellt ist da sind ja
doch
waren viele Dinge erlebbar in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten wo man den
Eindruck hat dass das Tischtuch mehr als
zerschnitten ist kommt das auch beim
Wähler an und wenn ja wie
das bemerkte Wähler wohl auch es ist für
Politik Beobachter zu denen ja auch ein
großer Teil der Wählerschaft gehört ja
lange schon sichtbar gewesen dass ich
Grüne und FDP so gut verstehen wie Hund
und Katze und diese Störungen
klimatische Art und bei der Setzung von
politischen Prioritäten sind natürlich
auch das Miteinander oder das
wechselseitige Behandlung des FDP
Finanzministers mit dem grünen
Wirtschaft und Energieminister in dieser
Koalition und das sehe ich der
Bundeskanzler hier zurückhält und nur
wenn es gar nicht anders geht klar macht
in welche Richtung das Regierungschef
navigieren soll das stärkt das Ansehen
der Regierung auch nicht das vermittelt
dann den Eindruck der Bundeskanzler sei
im Wesentlich ein Zauberer nun ist er
das auch aus guten Gründen weil die Lage
nun einmal so unübersichtlich geworden
ist und er sich anders als seine
Vorgänger Angela Merkel nicht einfach an
demoskopischen Beliebtheitswerten
orientieren kann denn die zufrieden
hatte mit ihrer Politik ist eben derzeit
verschwunden
vielleicht noch eine letzte Einschätzung
die erreichen Sie in Dresden das heißt
wir müssen durchaus noch mal diesen
Punkt machen den Demoskopen ja häufig
auch noch einmal herausarbeiten in ihren
Zahlenwerten also in dieser Einschätzung
dieser Performance dieser ampelregierung
aber eben auch im Zuspruch in die AFD
ähm wie weit kommt da dieser
ost-westgedanke mit rein
die AFD ist in Ostdeutschland pi mal
Daumen mehr als doppelt so stark als in
den westdeutschen Bundesländern die AFD
hat in Ostdeutschland die PDS
Schrägstrich Linkspartei als die Partei
des authentischen bevölkerungsprotestes
gegen Regierungspolitik abgelöst muss
auch die wählerstromanalysen
entsprechend zeigen und die AFD ist
überall dort stark wo früher einmal die
CDU stark gewesen ist insbesondere in
Thüringen und in Sachsen infolgedessen
wäre es gerade aus sächsischer
Perspektive hilfreich sich allmählich
nicht mehr mit der Hoffnung zu frieden
zu geben weil der AFD ist versammelten
sich im Grunde nur Faschisten und
Rassisten und wenn man deutlich genug
den Kampf gegen Rechts führen dann
würden die sich alles an so sehr schämen
dass sie vom Wald kurz bei der AFD
Abstand nehmen viel mehr Geld ist in
Sachsen und in Thüringen insbesondere zu
begreifen
davon eben viele Leute zu AFD hat
abwandern lassen weil die CDU nicht mehr
eine Partei auf der politischen Rechten
sein wollte sondern nur noch eine Partei
der politischen Mitte und an diesem Kurs
der CDU wird sich ein absehbarer Zeit
nichts ändern lassen weil die CDU
ohnehin nur noch gemeinsam mit dem
grünen und oder dem Sozialdemokraten
mehr deswegen ist wirklich kann die CDU
auch gar nichts anderes sein als eine
Partei der Mitte und deswegen wird
rechts von dir die AFD weiterhin stark
bleiben es sei denn sie verwandelt sich
in eine narzisstische Partei dann frage
ich sind ihre Zukunft Aussichten sehr
begrenzt
wir bedanken uns für ihre Einschätzungen
Professor Werner Patzelt
Politikwissenschaftler den wir in
Dresden erreicht haben herzlichen Dank
gern geschehen